Ever since The Walt Disney Company announced
its plans to acquire the majority of studio
20th Century Fox's assets in a $71.3 billion
merger set to be completed in 2019, one question
that has been on every superhero fan's mind
is whether or not Marvel Studios would recast
members of the X-Men.
After all, Disney's purchase of Fox does include
the entire slate of mutants who will soon
join the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
And just about no X-Man is more beloved than
Wolverine.
"Cuz I'm the best there is at what I do.
But what I do best isn't very nice."
Curiosity about such a recasting turned to
foaming-at-the-mouth excitement when longtime
X-Men film franchise producer Lauren Shuler
Donner told Slashfilm in February 2019 that
Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige would
start scouting for a younger actor to play
the next Wolverine as soon as the Disney-Fox
merger goes through.
From there, the internet kicked into overdrive
imagining who that younger actor might be.
And as odd as it sounds at first, social media
frequenters are unironically loving the idea
of Harry Potter series star Daniel Radcliffe
stepping up to portray the new Wolverine,
assuming the role that Australian actor Hugh
Jackman played from 2000 until 2017.
Piggy-backing off all the online chatter,
digital artist BossLogic created stunning
artwork imagining what Radcliffe could look
like as the hard-bitten, nearly indestructible
hero.
Though there's really no predicting which
actor Feige and the Marvel team will end up
tapping — and no one involved at either
Marvel or Fox has commented on the plausibility
of Radcliffe taking the role — the entire
situation actually started as a joke.
The idea gained popularity after Radcliffe
participated in a Wired Autocomplete Interview.
After answering a few Harry Potter-themed
questions, Radcliffe tackled the subject of
whether he is, in fact, the new Wolverine.
"There's gonna be a new Wolverine movie in
which it starts off with Hugh Jackman being
put into a hot wash.
And then when he comes out, it's me.
So yes!"
Radcliffe's joking tone made his answer seem
like total farce, but comic book fans were
quick to ponder whether the Harry Potter alum
could actually be telling the truth.
And surprisingly, a lot of people were down
for it, with a vast majority of Twitter users
arguing that Radcliffe would simply need to
bulk up before formally joining the X-Men
movie world.
One fan wrote in response,
"That could work.
Give him a year of protein shakes, growth
hormone, steak, creatine, testosterone injections,
chicken, rice, trained by The Mountain in
Iceland, and also eat lots of crumpets…
yeah that would work.
It's doable.
That would be awesome."
Another added that if British actor Tom Holland
can play the American superhero Spider-Man,
there's nothing stopping England-born Radcliffe
from portraying Wolverine.
A few fans who live and die by comic book
accuracy even noted that Radcliffe might be
better suited than Jackman ever was in one
regard: Wolverine is five-foot-three, while
Radcliffe is 5'6" and Jackman is a staggering
6'2".
Sadly, though, what began as a joke remains
just that.
Radcliffe has since come forward to clarify
his statements and make it crystal clear that
he isn't playing Wolverine — no confirmation
from Disney or Fox needed.
Speaking to IGN for a recent interview discussing
his new project, the TBS show Miracle Workers,
Radcliffe shared,
"This is what happens when you make jokes.
So, there you have it: Radcliffe won't become
the man behind the mutant.
But hey, if the internet didn't hate the thought
of pint-sized Radcliffe rising to serve as
the next Wolverine, it seems people may be
open to hearing other outside-the-box-ideas
— so long as the actor doesn't mind chugging
protein shakes and working out eleventeen hours a day.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.